it's a bit sweet that's probably a
little hoppy I don't know I like it it's
busy it's like really messed up but I
drink it missed out mostly because at
this place I can't believe I'm a DA the
American revolutionaries were beer
drinkers who fought for a free society
while the American experiment hasn't
always lived up to their expectations
they would be astounded by the
prosperity that we take for granted and
they would love today's American beer
the people who came from Europe to
settle in the Americas brought beer with
them English Dutch German and Czech
immigrants built breweries wherever they
settled and by 1870 there were more than
4,000 breweries in the US refrigeration
led to consolidation and decrease that
number to around 1500 by the beginning
of the 20th century and then of course
prohibition decimated the industry
completely only a small fraction of the
breweries managed to reopen after
prohibition was repealed during World
War two at the request of the government
many breweries produce lower alcohol
beer for the troops and our boys came
home with a taste for lighter beer in
the 1950s and 60s the construction of
the interstate highway system and the
emergence of TV led to the first
national brands live life every gold and
minute of it
enjoy Budweiser it reduced choice and
they could do it because they did can't
you know they achieve these economies of
scale that allow them to deliver product
at such inexpensive prices and by 1980
we were less than 50 breweries left the
United States I guess it's really cherry
blossom down rise right well I started
drinking at a very early age
I grew up and saved with us I was raised
on Budweiser and bush
I don't think it was any but in the
house when I was growing up there was
Falstaff hams the Pabst Blue Ribbon old
style was an important beer back then
and I'm in an old Milwaukee and all
these beers were they were they were
stuff you drank I grew up in eastern
Pennsylvania we drank in English
Schmitz sa ortley regional breweries
yeah went to college and ended up
working in a bar we have bud bud light
bush on top Budweiser's run out I throw
a bush keg on and nobody ever called me
but I think the first time I had a WOW
factor with beer was when I was in the
Navy in the Philippines drinking San
Miguel not just blew me away
I never had anything like that I moved
to New York City I played in an army
band and we started going to jazz clubs
and at that time in New York they had
just started importing bass ale pilsner
urquell is the import started creeping
in and people started detecting the
opportunity to buy differently they're
more expensive but it would seem well
worth it
craft beer microbrew is really grew out
of home brewing as people started making
bigger and more flavorful beers
Magnusson guys from their early the
early stage of Sierra Nevada 5 August
intention and that we've talked a bunch
with and they were like you know we just
made the beers that we like to make us
workers I ended up to Eureka to visit a
friend and stopped in the heartland
brewery and things have never been the
same
Blackhawk stouts sitting back in the
corner listening music drinking that
mysterious dark beer going what is this
and then of course you know the hops
happen to grow up north and his craft
room became more interesting out growers
started fooling around they came up with
new varieties they grow like little
flowers they look a lot like their they
have a cousin that's a marginally legal
medicinal herb they're not the
old-school hot we started making our IPA
in 95 rather immediately became our
flagship because the first people that
drank it said my god nobody's gonna
drink this we went yes may I show you
the brew house and honestly
balls will drive in by the computer
transferred to this tank here which is
the mash tun this is transferred to this
tank here which is called the louder
tongue that server water flows over here
to the kettle and then at the right
moment in the process some of this is
diverted those hop dosing enter from
here transferred to that tank down there
is mixed with yeast and direct it to a
fermentation tank 14 days later you have
beer this is where we keep Bob he has to
stay there he guards the tank from here
it goes back on into the brewery gets
filtered out to the bottling line
immediately out to the world I think one
of the most fascinating things about
craft beer is how innovated that it's
been it's taken traditional styles and
kind of ran with them and today more
styles are brewed in the United States
than any other country in the world the
craft brew is extraordinarily important
sort of in the kind of the economic
model of beer in the country in terms of
providing choices for people today's
beer industry includes about fourteen
hundred and forty breweries
four of which or about 95% of the
industry they make the very lightest
beer imaginable in order to create the
lowest common denominator of flavor so
that their marketing and their image is
what people buy into and there's nothing
about the flavor the challenge is that
decision for them bottom line there is a
difference and what light has it it's
called drinkability that just right
tastes not too heavy not too light but
those beers are extraordinarily
difficult to make and we couldn't make
one of our life depended on our beers
are big and robust and crazy and a lot
of ingredients that sort of like making
chili you know it's hard to make a bad
chili but you can make a more beautiful
chili if you work hard at it develop
some skills and that's the business that
we're all in I think you'll continue to
see the market being driven
by the crapper industry was the
fastest-growing segment it probably will
be four years yeah that's true
that's the best time to be a tool of
beer right now couldn't ask for a better
better thing on our leaving big rich
chocolatey L stout from Russia these
days in international competition not
only does the United States do better
than really any other country in the
last two years in the world Beer Cup for
example California the state itself won
more medals than every country except
for Germany USA best beer ever
there's the freedom choice and great
American beer for reason TV I'm Nicholas
you